so a lot of fun moments in the film one
of which a woman says something to the
effect that le men play a lot of games
true I'll agree with that but also Eliot
women play their own share of games I'm
not gonna actually tell you what those
are but at least filling in well and
here we go this is where this is the
worse can get really fun chat so as J
cuz J plays a guy that has a little bit
of a Casanova thing going on but in a
fun way if you were to coach a group of
LA ladies before they were going out in
the spirit of J what would you say to
one you're giving them like a Super Bowl
and the spirit of J in the spirit of day
yes EJ would give them false information
and then he would probably bet each one
of them down that's J for you okay but
actually I don't know
J just lives that's not true I don't
think Jade lies I think J just is very
honest about what he wants and who he is
so that I give him credit for if you're
gonna sit down a bunch one before the
other than act down I'd say hand over
drink always protect yourself from
everything and just be careful you know
just um I always say just yeah no
regrets you know if you if you're out to
have a fun time great go just don't
regress there's no advice you can give I
mean everyone's so different well
there's also the you know men really all
we want is honesty you know just tell us
what you want you know don't be bashful
I think the things are changing though I
think people are becoming more blunt I
think that we're we're through an age
right now where people are just saying
look I'm not looking for anything okay
we can a B and C and I think that that's
where things are going I have a lot of
friends to date a lot and that's the
world that they live in and um you know
makes it easier on them so just like
we're sort of communicating in 140
characters you want the same thing in
our relationships we're just looking for
something that's we're to the point
about it I mean it's that sort of foot
turn they're saying it's not like why I
have a pretense about it yeah I believe
so I'm
you know dating love all those things
they're hard you know you have to make a
lot of compromises in this world
especially in Los Angeles if you've
moved here for a career based life and
that's really what you came here it I'm
I'm guessing a you a lot of Drive behind
you so you have Drive to have the career
that you want and the dream and so now
when you throw a lovin in the mix and
you find a companion you have to make
compromises as well as they do to make
sure that both can co-exist yes they
both take a lot of work in order to do a
or B and so I think that that's where a
lot of the that the problems may arise
is you know one gets more love than the
other the career or the relationship and
it kind of falls to pieces yeah you can
only serve one master sort of thing and
also it helps to just smile and say yes
dear and sometimes keep the mouth shut
well you but you brought it up
technology I think also does complicate
things quite a bit it's like think about
how many times you miss read an email or
a text or I can't tell you how many
issues I have as a result of that so
like how do people ever really get
together when you say meet me at 3:00
a.m. don't tell my wife
it's not a mystery and